a friendship founded on business
is better than a business founded on
friendship
i do not think there is any other
quality so essential to success of any
kind as the quality of perseverance
it overcomes almost everything
even nature
the secret to success is to do the
common things uncommonly well
i would rather hire a man with
enthusiasm
than a man who knows everything
[Music]
i know of nothing more despicable and
pathetic
than a man who devotes all the hours of
the waking day
to the making of money for money's sake
if you want to succeed
you should strike out on new paths
rather than travel the worn paths of
accepted success
[Music]
i always tried to turn every disaster
into an opportunity
if your goal is to become rich
you will never achieve it
i would rather earn one percent off 100
people's efforts
than 100
of my own efforts
it is wrong to assume that men of
immense wealth are always happy
the only thing which is of lasting
benefit to a man
is that which he does for himself
money which comes to him without effort
on his part
is seldom a benefit
and often a curse
success comes from keeping the ears open
and the mouth closed
it is very important to remember what
other people tell you
not so much what you yourself already
know
[Music]
the ability to deal with people is as
purchasable a commodity as sugar or
coffee
and i will pay more for that ability
than for any other under the sun
the road to happiness lies in two simple
principles
find what it is that interests you
and that you can do well
and when you find it put your whole soul
into it every bit of energy and ambition
and natural ability you have
good leadership consists of showing
average people how to do work of
superior people
nobody does anything if he can get
anybody else to do it
he who works all day has no time to make
money
save when you can
and not when you have to
[Music]
the poorest man i know
is the man who has nothing but money
don't be afraid to give up the good to
go for the great
charity
is injurious
unless it helps the recipient to become
independent of it
[Music]
you